[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
[SQUEAKING]
GARY GENSLER:
Welcome to FinTech--
Shaping the World of Finance.
We're going to talk about
challenger banks today.
And we've chatted in our last
session about credit, payment
before that.
But challenger banks
is an interesting topic
that I thought we
should take a moment
and just talk about
challenger banks.
This is this concept built
upon building a bank that's
internet-only, building a bank
that has no bricks and mortar
office.
Now, it's not actually
a new concept.
And in this lecture, we're going
to talk a little bit about what
was happening even then
in the 1990s and the 2000s
when online banking started.
But this term, challenger
bank, and another related term,
neobanks, relates to
something a little bit later.
Ally Bank, which used to
be the old auto lending
part of General
Motors, the largest--
at one point, at one point
the largest auto manufacturer
in the US--
Ally Bank in 2009 decided
it was not just going
to be an auto lender.
They're going to become a bank.
And in 2009, they
said they were going
to be an internet-only bank.
Over in Europe, and
particularly the United Kingdom,
many people say challenger
banks started in Europe,
in the United
Kingdom, particularly
when the official
sector got involved
and through something
called the Payment Systems
Directive and the Payment
System Directive 2
and then later in the United
Kingdom around open banking--
we've talked about
this, about open APIs--
that it opened up the
system a little bit.
And by 2013 to 2015, you saw a
slew of these challenger banks
and neobanks getting
into this space,
first particularly in
Europe, then a lot in the US,
now around the globe.
You can find challenger
banks and neobanks in Brazil,
in India, and Southeast
Asia, in China.
Some of them have been
started by big tech companies.
And in the last
few years, you have
big finance reacting as well,
like Goldman Sachs starting
Marcus.
And so now the term
gets a little loose.
Is a challenger bank and
neobank if Goldman Sachs
is starting Marcus?
That doesn't feel like
a challenger bank.
Goldman Sachs is established
140, 150-year-old investment
bank.
So it gets a little blurry.
And I admit that in this
space, there's sometimes
terms don't fit well together.
I'm going to upload
the slides here
for a second and share slides.
But Romain is there any
questions as we're starting?
TA: Nothing so far, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: So we're
going to go back to a topic
that we didn't have
quite enough time
to finish in class seven, credit
scoring and alternative data.
And it's an important
topic that underlies
some of what's going on
with challenger backs, not
everything.
And then we're going to talk
about some traditional banking,
online banking as it sort
of began in the late '90S
and in the noughts.
And what is this new wave,
neo or challenging banks,
some of how they're funded and
their own valuations, and then
the big finance reaction.
So back to data--
there is a company.
Many of us know it as FICO.
It's actually called the Fair
Isaac Company, started 60
some years ago, started
by two Stanford graduates,
not MIT, but a very
good institution.
And they were more
into data analytics.
And remember, credit cards
had started in the 1950s.
And here it was, the
late '50s, early 60s,
a fintech company of its time
trying to do analysis on data.
A gentleman named Fair and
a gentleman named Isaac--
I don't recall
their first names,
I think one was Bill Isaac--
start this company.
It's a data analytics company.
And by the late 1970s,
it had taken hold.
By the 1980s, it was
the dominant player
for consumer credit ratings.
And their system is now
used in 32 countries.
And many other companies are
using the FICO score system.
But it's only one system.
And this gives you a
little bit of background.
It's about what your amounts
that you owe, the payment
history on those credit cards
and other bank relations.
Are you taking out new credit?
We could do a whole class
just on FICO scores.
They have updated it
at least eight times.
And in the summer
of 2020, I think
they're rolling out FICO 9.0.
It's possibly FICO 10.0.
So it's not static, but
it's built in another era.
It's built in an era
about your payment history
around your bank credit.
It doesn't include
many of the things
that we would normally
think to include.
And so what is it that
we're going through now?
We're going through
a period of time
where folks are saying,
well, wait a minute,
maybe there are other
ways, alternative ways
to figure out and
assess your credit.
And it's called
alternative data.
Alternative Data in a sense is
just alternative to whatever
FICO might be using.
This could be your bank,
checking, employment, income,
insurance, tenant, utilities.
All of this currently
is not in FICO scoring.
Now, in some countries,
employment data and income data
is already and has been for
decades used for consumer
credit underwriting.
But in the US and up
to 30 other countries
using the FICO
scores, a lot of this,
even this classic
information like did you
pay your rent on time, did you
pay your utilities on time,
is not necessarily
included in FICO.
It's partly because they didn't
have the data in the 1970s
when Fair and Isaac
were doing this.
And eight versions
later, they still
haven't included a lot
of utility and tenancy.
OK, secondly, there's something
called cash flow underwriting.
And if we go to China and
we go to payment wallets
around the globe, but let's stay
with China, Alipay and WeChat
Pay now can really see
a lot of your cash flow,
not just your expenditures,
but your revenues, if you're
moving your income in on some
regular basis into a wallet.
And cash flow underwriting is
even more relevant-- again,
let's stay with
Alipay for a moment--
about small and
medium-sized enterprises.
So whether it's Alipay
in China or Toast,
a payment start up in the
restaurant business here
in the US, Toast can start
to see all the revenues
and expenditures of a restaurant
and sort of make a credit
decision based upon that.
So cash flow underwriting
is a very important thing.
You don't necessarily
need machine learning
or AI to incorporate
this alternative data.
But the alternative data is
something that FICO doesn't do.
And classic banking, doing
small and medium-sized lending,
doesn't necessarily do good
cash flow underwriting.
Romain any questions?
TA: None so far on this topic.
We got one question from
Luke that perhaps you
can touch upon later on
why online banking started
in Europe versus other regions.
GARY GENSLER: OK, OK.
Let me hold the Luke question
when we get into that as well.
Your consumption,
your purchase data--
Visa and Mastercard
already are looking at this
to cross-sell to us.
And others are looking
at it to cross-sell.
If you're buying sports
equipment or hiking equipment,
we, all of a sudden,
get advertising for it.
But can alternative
data, like what you buy,
relate to your credit?
Well, let's talk about
something that's been
known for some time.
I don't know how
many of you would
have ever, when you went to
replace an automobile tire,
decide to get it retreaded.
Literally, a retread is
putting rubber, new rubber
on the old tire.
Now, retreads or
something that we
don't usually talk about
in a finance course.
But it has been
shown that those who
buy retreads are a little bit
more susceptible to credit
risk, meaning default, meaning
they're a higher risk credit.
What if you could track
people's purchases,
whether it's automobile
retreads versus new tires--
you see the difference--
or anything else
that in the purchase
history gives you a sense,
is this a higher risk credit
or a lower risk credit?
You can take purchase
and consumption data
and tie it to are they
higher insurance risk?
Are they a higher
risk in their credit?
Now, you have to be careful.
You have to be careful to comply
with local law and societal
norms about not using
alternative data that might be
suggestive of something else.
It might be suggestive
of cultural differences,
of race or gender
or ethnic background
or sexual orientation.
And if your consumption
of purchase data
has to do with that and you end
up with something in the US,
you could easily be
on the wrong side
of what's called the
Equal Credit Opportunity
Act, that you have to
basically be fair and unbiased
in your extension of credit.
And this is sort of
at the cutting ground
of alternative data, is
how does alternative data
get used, but not inadvertently,
or worse, purposely,
trip up fairness
and bias issues.
And we saw that recently
with Apple Credit Card.
Apple Credit Card rolled
out in the spring of 2019--
a partnership between
Apple, Goldman Sachs' Marcus
and Mastercard, a
new, innovative thing
that big tech was
rolling out with big
find in the spring of 2019.
And all of a sudden,
a venture capitalist
runs into the Apple
Credit Card and finds
that he and his spouse
were going to get
10 times different credit.
They file tax returns together.
They were together, apparently
worth many millions of dollars,
maybe centimillionaire.
And he starts to
advertise on Twitter
and promote that the Apple
Credit Card had a problem.
And then Steve Wozniak,
the co-founder of Apple,
publicly announces that he
ran into the same problem
with his wife and himself.
Again, they filed
their taxes together.
They're both
extraordinarily wealthy.
Why would one have 10
times or 20 times more
the credit than the other?
There seemed to be,
for whatever reason,
some gender bias in the Apple
Credit allocation alternative
data system.
Now, we don't know yet
to this day what it was.
But what we do know is that
Apple Credit Cards stubbed
their toe on their rollout.
Sometimes it's about the law.
Sometimes, though,
it's about business.
Sometimes it's about
breaking societal norms.
But in that case, Apple
had a tough rollout.
They roll out Apple Credit Card.
And yet they have
the co-founder,
former founder of Apple
saying not so fast,
you've got a problem here.
The other sets of data
is our social footprint,
our social and media
footprint-- app usage,
browsing history, the like,
geolocation, et cetera.
And in this world of
coronavirus and the crisis,
we know that geolocation
is going to be used
and is already likely being
used for a lot of contact
tracing in many
countries, certainly
in Korea from the news reports.
And I'm guessing Luke could
tell us more about that.
But we know that
contact tracing and all
of the attributes of figuring
out who we are as an individual
are being traced more and more.
In China, there's a social
credit scoring system
that is an official
part of the government's
approach to extending credit.
It might be whether you
can buy an airline ticket.
It may be whether you can
even get on the commuter rail
system, depending
upon your app usage.
And that app usage in
China even includes, as I
understand it, not just your--
what you're doing
on Alipay or WeChat
Pay, but also what you're
doing on dating websites.
Literally, I repeat
on dating websites,
and whether and how you're
on any website or any app
could be a little bit
like the tire retreading,
that you might be--
you might find, through
the alternative data,
that it's a little different.
Here in the US, many
fintech companies
are approaching the
regulators and saying
we don't want to trip up and be
on the wrong side of the Equal
Credit Opportunity Act.
We don't want to be on the
wrong side of other laws,
like Fair Credit Reporting,
Truth in Lending Act,
and a series of other laws.
Please help us,
regulators, interpret
how we can use alternative
data, how we can actually
be more inclusive, provide
more and better finance
to more people at a
lower cost, but not
be on the wrong side of
these important societal
and legal norms.
So it's a very
interesting place.
I'll use one example from a
conversation with Lending Club.
I had the honor
to be on a stage--
before the crisis, one
of the last conferences
was an MIT fintech conference.
And I was on the stage with
the CEO of Lending Club
and having a good
interview, a fireside chat.
And I asked about alternative
data and how they use it.
They use it.
But what they find is in
using alternative data
in that marketplace
lending company,
they then use machine learning
on the alternative data.
They find some what they
believe to be correlations.
And then they just use straight
up regression analysis.
Once they identify
an attribute, they
put the machine
learning to the side.
They've used it.
But then they sort of then go
to the down-scaled old way,
just straight up.
That's an attribute
we've identified.
Tire retreads matter.
Let's just use it that way.
So they do it by trying
to find some attributes
and then move on, as I
understood the conversation.
So there's a tremendous
ecosystem in alternative data,
too.
This is just a
slide that pulled.
You can readily get these types
of slides on the internet.
But this is from CB Insights
as to alternative data sources.
This is a bunch of companies--
I wouldn't necessarily
call them fintech startups,
but they're companies
trying to service,
here's how we can help
you either with machine
learning, AI, or
actually sources
of data in this whole space.
So I'm going to move on to the
challenger bank discussion,
but pause for a moment to
see if there are questions.
I know Luke had a question,
but that was really
about challenger banks.
So [Romain?
TA: Hassan.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yeah.
I mean, if you
could just elaborate
on cash flow underwriting.
I do not quite get it.
GARY GENSLER: So let's do
it in a small business.
And let's use either the
example of toast in the US
with restaurants or
almost any business
that Alipay has the wallet.
What Alipay or Toast and
see on that small business
or restaurant is they
can see their revenues
and they can see their
expenditures to the extent
that it's kept inside
that payment architecture.
So in Alipay, they've
incentivized the millions
of merchants using Alipay
not only to receive revenues
into their Alipay Wallet, but
also to pay their suppliers
with the Alipay Wallet.
So what Alipay
can do and does do
is they can start to see the
entire picture or 80% or 90%
of the picture.
They might not see
the entire picture,
but they can literally build a
whole 360 degrees around them.
Or take something like
Intuit here in the US,
which is the company
that was founded
20 plus years ago that has
the most dominant sort of tax
software, TurboTax.
Intuit is also in
the fintech space.
They recently announced
buying Credit Karma
for billions of dollars.
And they also have
other fintech offerings,
where they can maybe
build a greater picture.
I call it cash
flow underwriting.
It means underwriting,
assessing the risk,
because you can see the revenues
and expenditures and build,
in essence, an income
statement on the merchant.
Amazon can do some of that, not
completely as well as Alipay.
But Amazon can do some of
that through Amazon Prime
and what they can
see on the merchant.
Did that help?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARY GENSLER: And it gives
them a competitive advantage.
And it's part of why getting
into the payment space
before getting into
the credit space
is a business model,
particularly in big tech.
Now, I'm not saying
that's what was
the initial reason that Alipay
got into the payment space.
Alipay was trying to promote
their online platform.
Amazon got into
the payment space
to promote their
online platform.
And even Toast, the
restaurant software business,
got into the restaurant
business to sell tablets.
They were thinking we'll
sell the better hardware
to the restaurateurs,
because this tablet was
important for the
servers, what we
might call waiters
and waitresses,
walking around a restaurant.
But what they quickly
found is that the Toast--
this is the example--
they pivoted from being a
hardware tablet business
to being a payment business.
And then they start to be
a credit business as well,
because the data they're
receiving in a partial cash
flow underwriting-- they
don't have a full 360--
allows them to start to
underwrite in that business.
And frankly, they're likely
to be able to do it better
than a traditional bank.
A traditional bank
that might get
annual or quarterly
financials will not
have quite the up-to-date
sensitivity as to how
that restaurant's doing.
TA: And we have a question from
Danielle about data aggregators
on the slide.
GARY GENSLER: Please, please.
TA: Are the different
data aggregator players
for the purposes of selling
to fintech customers
or for selling to
companies who want
to use the data for
personalized advertising?
And if yes, why?
Do you anticipate
any consolidation?
GARY GENSLER: No,
I think Danielle
raised a good question.
They're data aggregators.
And the terms, again, are
not terribly well-defined.
They're data aggregators
that could be there,
as Danielle points out,
to cross-market, to sell.
And even-- let's use
Credit Karma for a minute.
Credit Karma initially was
about providing free access
to your credit report.
That was their initial insight.
What they found over time
is they could cross-sell
and become a friendly
website for free
to give you access to credit.
They were cross-selling.
But then they were
also collecting a fee.
And they were
collecting more data.
And inevitably, they had
100 plus million files,
even though they had
much fewer customers.
But data aggregation could
also come from another space.
Plaid, Galileo, and
others, we call them also
data aggregators.
And they started as
software providers
to provide an open
API, as we discussed.
But then they create
a data warehouse.
And they become
data aggregators.
So the term data aggregator
can be used in many ways.
One small way it can be used
is the second way Danielle
mentioned, and it's kind
of mentioned on this slide
of alternative data.
There's some companies that
just said we will collect data.
FICO score doesn't
have utility data.
We'll collect the utility
data and rental payment data.
We believe it will become an
alternative data aggregator.
So yes, they're are
data aggregator.
But they're collecting
data with the clear mind
that they're going to
enhance credit scoring.
And as we turn now
to challenger banks,
challenger banks
might say, look,
we don't have the
ability in our first year
or even maybe 10
years of business
to be the one collecting all
that utility and rent payment
or social media data.
We want to turn
to somebody else.
You might create
a business simply
to say we are going to
be a data aggregator
to enhance the underwriting
of these banks.
There's hundreds of
challenger banks.
I want to be a service provider
to those challenger banks.
So Danielle, good question.
It could be on marketing.
It could be that
you've got there
because you were in the business
of something else, payments
or credit scoring,
like Credit Karma.
Or you could
specifically say I just
want to have a
business model simply
about an alternative
data field that I think
and my machine
learning might tell me
that alternative
data field is going
to give us better underwriting.
And then I will sell to
all the other fintechs.
I will service fintechs
by collecting data.
Romain anything else, or--
TA: We have Nikhil and
Brian with their hands up.
Go ahead, you two.
GARY GENSLER: OK, Nikhil or
Brian and then we'll move on.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
around underwriting
based on cash flows.
So I wrote my paper
on alternative data.
And something that
came out was most
of the alternative
data lending firms are
focused on small businesses.
So the Amazon example that you
gave is for their suppliers.
Is there regulation
in the US that's
preventing a cash-flow-based
underwriting for customers?
Because countries like
Kenya have it with M-Shwari.
Baidu piloted
something with Zest AI.
So just curious, what's limiting
cash-flow-based underwriting
in the US specifically?
GARY GENSLER: I think
it's a great question.
I think it's not
just regulatory.
It's also that as
of now, as of now,
the folks they could probably
do the best cash flow
underwriting on us are
the banks themselves,
that Bank of America and Citi
sees your rent payment going
out, sees your Visa
payments going out,
and sees your wages coming in.
I mean, literally
the banks themselves.
And yet, they have not,
as I understand it,
yet done a full 360
cash-flow underwriting.
A number of them are enhancing
their credit card products
and enhancing those products by
taking the FICO scores and then
sort of like FICO plus a little.
But interestingly, the big
banks have collected together
and formed something
called Vantage,
which is a competitor to FICO.
And it's a sort of consortium
amongst some big banks.
But it doesn't fully
include the income side.
And I think it does relate to
some of the regulatory issues
here in the US.
In the earlier wave, in the
earlier wave of data analytics
in the 1960s--
remember, credit cards came
along in the '50s and '60s--
we passed two really
important laws--
one about bias, called Equal
Credit Opportunity Act,
and one about credit
reporting agencies.
These companies like
TransUnion and Equifax,
they're regulated under the
Fair Credit Reporting Act.
And a lot of banks,
they're just sort of
trying to work
through those issues.
And again, this sets up the
challenger bank discussion.
It's part of why challenger
banks around the globe--
they started more in Europe--
but the challenger banks around
the globe had an alternative.
This is one of the
reasons I think that they
have a bit of an alternative.
I think this is
where we're headed.
We will, as individuals,
be more looked at this way.
One little story-- there
was one other question,
Romain I'm sorry, who was it?
TA: Brian.
GARY GENSLER: Brian and
then one little story
close out alternative data.
AUDIENCE: Could you
please talk about how
legislation, such as GDPR and
other similar legislation,
has affected this space?
GARY GENSLER: So great question.
There's also privacy concerns
about sharing my data.
Now, we all share our data.
That sort of horse
is out of that barn.
But then society
sort of says wait,
what's your protection here?
You're at the forefront of this,
passes the GDPR, the General
Directive, and the
P is not privacy.
I'm sorry, I can't
remember the--
AUDIENCE: Protection something.
GARY GENSLER: Protection
Regulation, data-- data
protection, that's right,
General Data Protection
Regulation.
And they passed GDPR, basically
the right to be forgotten,
the rights about your
information, the right
to basically review
it and so forth.
It has some similarities
to those laws that
were way back in the 1970s
called Fair Credit Reporting
Act, even, but a lot further.
And what these privacy laws,
and more recently in the US,
the California Consumer
Protection Act or CCPA--
we all got notices in 2019
and regarding from Google
and others about the CCPA.
What they've done is they've
leaned into an ability for you
to review your data and
potentially edit your data
and delete some of
what's being tracked.
It does raise some of
the R data protection--
General Data
Protection Regulation.
But it doesn't go to the heart
of whether using the data
is going to lead to
biased outcomes, which
is about fairness
and equal credit,
or whether you're going to be
regulated like a credit agency.
So I think the GDPR and CCPA
better protect the public.
They also raise some of
the costs and barriers
to entry in this field.
So there's some economics to it.
I think they might also tend
a little bit towards then
homogeneic outcomes, meaning
that all the banks will
be doing similar things
to protect themselves
in the regulatory environment.
So I think it's a consideration.
It doesn't necessarily
slow this down.
It's also an opportunity
for a fintech startup.
If you think you can
be GDPR-CCPA compliant
and still be a really talented
alternative data aggregator,
that's an opportunity for you.
If you're ahead of the
regulatory curve and lower
regulatory risk for
the other startups,
so that's an opportunity.
One little comment
on alternative data
that I like to mention--
and I don't remember where
I read this, so I apologize.
I can't quote this--
the study accurately.
But there has been
a study about credit
as it relates to
charging your phones.
And so I just pass
this along to you,
that if some alternative data
provider and alternative data
underwriter wants to
assess whether you or I are
good credit, apparently, if one
charges your phone every night,
we're more likely to repay our
credit card and personal loans.
And if you don't charge
your phone every night,
that's fine with me.
That's totally fine.
But apparently, you're a little
bit higher risk for credit.
That's what one
survey has shown.
And I apologize.
I just don't even remember
all the things I've
read, where I've breaded this.
And so what if some
challenger bank just tracks
whether you charge your phone?
By the way, that's
not hard to do.
It's easy.
These phones are really
quite sophisticated--
geolocation, tracking,
contact tracing, everything.
So let's talk about the
readings and everything.
I'm not going to dive into it.
But there were three readings
about challenger banks,
neobanks, and some of the
challenges going forward
in this field.
What is a challenger
bank or neobank?
And since we're--
I don't want to run out of time.
Let me just sort of say
challenger and neobank are
often used interchangeably,
but they're actually--
to the more sort of specific,
they're a little bit different.
A neobank is something
that is acting like a bank
but is not yet
registered or licensed
as a bank in its jurisdiction.
And a challenger
bank more technically
would be something
that has a license.
Now, most people use these
terms interchangeably.
But there's slight differences.
Do they have yet registered?
And challenger
banks and neobanks
are used to talk
about this thing that
happened in these last
seven to ten years.
I'm going in a little
bit talk about how
this relates to the online
banking that came before it.
The pain points in
traditional banking--
we're going to dive into this
in a minute in a few slides.
So I'll hold off.
But those pain points about the
costs that the big banks have,
the bricks and mortar legacy
business that they have,
the legacy technology
are real and they've
provided some opportunity
to challenger banks.
And the question is how will
challenger banks and neobanks
affect the landscape?
So one is what is
this phenomena?
Two, why have they been
able to tap into this?
What's the traditional
bank's problems?
And three, what's it
mean for the future?
That's what we're going to
try to cover going forward.
So the challenges--
I mentioned a couple of them,
but look, we all know it.
In the US, there's about 78,000
branches still in the US.
That's down from about
82,000 or 83,000.
What will that number
be in 10 years?
It's not declining
leaps and bounds.
But particularly after
the coronavirus crisis,
whenever we get to the
other side of this,
whether it optimistically is in
months or more, realistically,
in a couple of years and we--
all this social distancing
starts to move
around and we start
to get out there, this 78,000
branches, do we need them all?
And yet surveys of the
public, still people
like to have a physical branch
for that occasional time you
go into a physical branch.
They have legacy technology.
The products themselves
are somewhat commoditized.
A mortgages a mortgage, by
and large, an auto loan,
and even a small business loan.
There's a certain
commoditization
of payments and credit.
And how, when you still have
4,000 to 5,000 banks in the US
and in many countries
still hundreds of banks,
how do they literally
compete with each other
on a product that is
somewhat commoditized?
Now, you might say that's
hard for the new competitor.
But the new competitor
then comes in and says,
well, maybe I can only provide
something to the restaurant
business, or I can provide
something that is really
a great user interface.
And the cost and
fees are real, too.
The traditional
banking, not just
because of their branch network
of nearly 80,000 branches
in the US, but also because
of their employment,
also because of their fees--
a lot of the challenger banks
broke in by saying, listen,
we're not going to charge
you the same overdraft fees
or late fees.
And if you do a deep dive and
a deep study on one consumer
banking, a lot of the
revenue is on fees,
whether it's overdraft,
late fees and the like.
And so challenger banks
also said we can go in there
and try to challenge online in
a different way and, of course,
provide greater user interface.
I think, to Luke's
earlier question,
partly why challenger
banks started in Europe
was partly because of the
Payment System directive.
There was first PDS,
Payment System Directive,
what's now called 1 and PSD 2.
I think it's partly
because of the Payment
System directives, but
partly the 2008 crisis.
Now, Ally Bank here
in the US technically
was the first one in 2009 here.
But a lot of people don't
say that was the first one.
But that came after the crisis.
And then you saw
this spur of them
in the early teens
that came along.
And I think a lot of it
had to do with trust.
And the European situation
it was going through,
the European debt crisis, all
the way through 2012, 2013.
And you saw an enormous
number of these starting
between 2011 and 2015.
And so this is a little bit
the history of online banking.
And I take this from
FT Partners, which
is Financial Technology
Partners, which
is a small investment bank
started by a former Wall Street
banker, I think a
handful from Goldman
and maybe Morgan
Stanley and the others.
But we're not going to
go through each of these.
But the Bank of
Scotland actually
started to do online
banking back in 1983.
In essence, anything you think
is new has something way back.
Bank of America was
already online by 2001.
Yodlee, which is-- we talked
about Yodlee when we talked
about APIs--
had already been
in this business.
And ING, which was part of
a big insurance company,
started retail banking
in the late '90s.
The internet came along.
An earlier wave of
fintech developed
and online banking came along.
Most of it, most of it
related to traditional banks.
And the distinction that I
draw between online banking
and challenger banking--
it's a light distinction, but an
important one-- online banking
generally was
related to companies
that had bricks and mortars,
traditional business models,
generally-- not
always, not always.
And Mint was launched in 2006,
later acquired by Intuit.
That tax software
company acquired Mint.
ING, an insurance company,
has something that Capital One
buys for $9 billion in 2011.
So the earlier wave of
non-banking online banking,
non-traditional banking,
like ING Direct and Mint,
were acquired.
They were eaten up, taken up.
And Ally-- Ally was an
auto lending company
formed 100 years ago
by General Motors.
It was the first captive
auto lending company.
But this set this
stage to what if I just
started something that
never had a banking license,
never had a bricks and mortar?
It's just a start up.
I'm just going to go into
some of these cracks,
some of these opportunities
the traditional banks
are giving me-- costs, fees,
trust, user interface--
and I'm going to
start something.
And so what are the reasons?
And from a survey,
from a different group,
The Financial Brand,
these are just
some of the reasons
people are saying.
It's easy to set up an account.
I like the fees and the rates.
Better experience,
quality service, in one
survey a couple of months ago.
That's an opportunity as well.
Here's a list.
You can make the
list so much longer.
There's hundreds
of other companies.
But what I tried
to do in this is
sort of stick to around
the world different banks.
Ally Bank from 11
years ago, but look
at the spate of startups
in 2013 to 2016 or '16.
Now, some of these are
new, like BigPay in India.
Some of them are multi-billion
valuation companies already,
like Nubank in Brazil,
started about seven years ago.
There's a bulk of them
from the UK, like OakNorth.
Now, Revolut is in
30 countries now,
one of the earliest and
largest out of Europe.
Some are coming from
other fintech space.
Like SoFi didn't start as what
people would traditionally
call a challenger bank.
SoFi kind of started as an
online lending platform,
not quite peer to peer.
But then SoFi is moving over.
You can put on this
list Betterment
that we will talk about
in the next lecture that
does wealth management.
Betterment is starting
to move into this space.
Plaid has started to say they
will move into this space.
And then WeBank is
an interesting one
that's really formed by a
bunch of commercial banks
in China that's saying
we're going to just have
an online platform.
Is it really part of those
commercial banks or is it
separately a challenger bank.
So I've got a lot going
on, and KakaoBank,
which is started by one
of the big tech firms.
I chose not to put
Ant Financial on here.
But you could arguably say
Ant Financial, part of Alipay.
I was trying to stick to things
that are really classically
called challenger neobanks.
So the vocabulary
is a little loose.
Most people, when they think
of challenger neobanks,
they think of Revolut in Europe.
If you want to study
a case closely,
look at Revolut,
now in 30 countries.
But a lot of other players
who try to get in--
TransferWise from
the payment space.
So some from the payment
space some, from the big tech,
like KakaoBank, some
from commercial banks,
some from investment banks, like
Goldman Sachs starts Marcus.
A lot going on.
Nearly every country--
Australia is represented
here, China, Southeast Asia
and the like.
But this sort of
gives you a map of it,
back to that FT Partners thing.
This blows it up even more,
just with their logos.
But you can see it's really
around the globe right now.
Kind of was emanated out of
Europe, populated out of the US
then, and then all
of a sudden, you just
saw it kind of all
around the globe.
Brazil, enormous contributions
out of Brazil in the business
models as well and the like.
Paytm out of India as well, in a
sense, I should have mentioned.
Quite a sort of
interesting-- and this
will be up in Canvas, of course.
So what are their
product offerings?
What are their
Well, any bank has the same sort
of list of product offerings,
of course.
And this is just one example,
again, from this FT Partners.
Checking and savings--
to be a challenger bank,
it's usually right
there, somewhere in debit
cards, credit cards,
checking, savings.
And basically, they would say
it was easy to an account.
And we will actually
pay you something.
Revolut, interestingly, started
in the cross-border payment
area and basically said
you could have an account--
you can be in one
country and you
could have an account
in multiple currencies.
Traditional banking is a
single-currency product, partly
regulation, partly history.
But Revolut says we're online.
You can have
multiple currencies.
And we won't charge you all
of that cross-border cost.
One might say it started
as a payment company.
But it was really an offering
you accounts as well.
And this idea of
offering an account--
remember, the term neobank
and challenger bank,
often used interchangeably,
but neobank is something
that's not yet licensed.
You've seen a spate of companies
in the United Kingdom getting
licensed from 2016 to 2019.
Many that were not licensed
as traditional banks
then filed for their
banking licenses.
And you've seen that
happening along the way.
When will SoFi, for instance,
get their banking license
in the US, so to speak.
You'll see that sort of
going along the way as well.
Romain I'm just going to pause
for questions just to see--
get a little engaged here.
And then I'm going to go
to their account base.
And we're going to talk
about their account base.
And then we'll turn to funding,
valuations, and a little bit
how traditional
banks are reacting.
TA: Excellent.
Alessandro, do you want to go?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
Hi, Gary.
So my question is many
of these companies
that offer credit cards, they
often partner up with banks.
Is this because of regulatory
issues or a balance
sheet issues?
GARY GENSLER: It's
a great question.
It's really both.
And it's not just--
it's not just in the
credit card business.
You found that
marketplace lenders also
partnered up with banks.
The idea of entering
part of finance--
you always have a decision
in any business of buy
versus build or
rent versus bill.
You can do this with
your cloud storage.
Do I want to build my
data warehouse or rent it?
Well, by and large, if
you're a fintech startup,
you're going to rent your
cloud storage now, right?
You're not going to build
your data warehouse.
You might similarly rent
somebody else's balance sheet.
And so part of what you've
seen is about balance sheet.
You start a business and you
try to find some funding,
but you don't have
the funding yourself.
You don't have a balance sheet.
And you can get a
warehouse line of credit.
And you can use the asset
securitization market
as well to offload those credit
card receivables, those auto
receivables, student
loan, and, of course,
mortgage receivables.
And-- excuse me--
[SNEEZES] and so you see
[SNEEZES] in some lines
of business,
particularly mortgages,
that what one might call
alternative finance--
Quicken Loans,
PennyMac, and others
have built very
significant-- well
over 50% of mortgages in
the US now, 50% to 60%,
originated by the non-banks
because they can readily
offload the balance
sheet issues.
But to your question, a lot
of it is also regulatory.
And in the credit card space
and in the peer-to-peer lending
space, without a
bank license, it's
hard to do all the
pieces you need to do.
And without kind of diving into
each of the regulatory reasons
why, you tend to--
so Amazon partnered with
Synchrony, for instance.
And subsequent,
it looks like they
may have also partnered with
JPMorgan Chase on credit card
offerings.
And there are banks, like
Synchrony and others,
they will say we'll
basically white label.
Some of them, like
Synchrony, that's a co-brand,
on Amazon-Synchrony.
Some will say we'll just
be in the background.
And there are actually
some licensed banks
that make a business out of
servicing fintech companies.
And there's a whole
group of licensed banks
that in both Europe
and the US feel
that's a line of business
in and of itself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TA: Martin.
AUDIENCE: Yes,
with so many banks
and with so many similar
credit offerings,
how do you see the
differentiation will happen?
And there--
GARY GENSLER: Great question.
Look, this is a
very exciting space,
but it's going to shake out.
I mean, it's hard to imagine
that they'll all be there.
There is one website--
I didn't choose to put it up
here-- that actually follows
the top 10 challenger
banks, by every six months,
they post who is getting
the most web traffic?
And part of it-- if you're
SoFi, and in one year
you get the most web traffic,
but three years later, people
aren't going on your
website, that's a problem.
I'm not saying SoFi
yet has that problem.
So the way that these
companies-- they've each
started a little different.
Some start in a
slice of a domain,
like Revolt is the cross-border.
Some come at it from
the open API side.
Some come from
the low-cost side.
They find one pain point and
they try to do that well.
All of them that are successful
now pretty much started
between 2013 and 2018.
So it's a little harder
to think somebody
is going to get in now.
But it might be a geography.
It might be like BigPay, which
I think is in Southeast Asia.
It might be a geography as well.
But I do think
there's going to be--
there's going to be shakeout.
And even amongst
the unicorns, those
that are valued over $1
billion, customers matter.
And maybe this sets up.
I'm going to show
you two competing
charts on challenger banks.
This is just Europe.
But you see the
growth in customers--
Revolt, N26, Monese
and so forth,
just this remarkable
growth of customers.
That's getting noted
by traditional banks.
You get 5, 10 million
customer accounts, that's
a remarkable thing to happen.
We'll talk more about
this when we do asset
management in the next lecture.
But most of the biggest online
brokers, to give you scaling,
were somewhere between 6 and
12 million customer accounts,
E-Trade and the like,
TD Ameritrade, so forth.
So to give this on a scale
of customer accounts,
these started to
really get noticed.
And another customer
account chart--
different service, it's hard to
know whether these numbers are
accurate, but these are
self-reported by the companies.
This is by year of crop,
the 2013 startups--
Nubank, Aspiration,
Tandem, Chime.
Well, Nubank getting to 15
million customer accounts
or KakaoBank in Korea getting
to 10 million customers,
Chime, 6 million, 5 million
for MoneyLion, Revolut, 6,
and some other figures
show Revolut might
be closer to 9 million now--
these are significant
in and of themselves,
that they can get to that.
So part of a business model--
you can see hundreds
of challenger banks.
But many of them still only have
100,000 to 400,000 accounts.
And that's a great
start, but you've
got to kind of get further.
And the venture
capitalists behind it
have to decide what's
their exit strategy?
Can you sell this to
somebody else who's
trying to get a foothold
in this space or not?
Stash, by the way,
that's listed here
is more in the online
brokerage business than it
on an online banking.
So I chose not to
list it earlier.
Tandem, only half a
million customers,
is a really big one in the UK.
But Starling Bank and
Revolut and Monzo are bigger.
So how does Tandem
break through when
you've got four or five that
are bigger, just as an example,
in the UK?
And so then valuations--
and it's really hard to
get behind valuations.
All of this is before
the corona crisis.
Some of these are
going to be winners.
Some of them are going to
be losers, this one taken
from a Forbes article
in late 2019 based
on PitchBook Data from
their last funding round.
Now, Nubank-- look,
let's go back.
Nubank, 15 or so
million customers--
Nubank's been the big
success story here.
Revolut, if that's a true number
from their last funding round,
that seems a little out of
what the customer numbers are.
It might be an
out-of-date figure.
Valuations aren't clear.
This is not stock
market valuation.
So I'm going to give you
another take on this as well,
is this is the actual funding--
back to the FT Partners survey--
this is actual funding that
these companies have done
and then what they call
pre-money valuations of Nubank
and Chime and some
of the others.
So these are not insignificant
players in the market.
If you're thinking about going
to work for one of these,
it would be an
exciting career path.
But even the Nubanks
and Chimes and N26s
have to figure out how they stay
viable, how they stay vibrant
against the traditional players
and the big tech companies.
And if you're all the
way at the other end,
if you're a company like Dave--
Dave is thought of as
just maybe a unicorn
and it's only raised 76 million.
Now, that number
may or may not--
but if you're Dave and you're
there with a couple employees,
will it be there in
three years or not?
What's their exit strategy?
So I think you've raised
the right question
about all of these.
And the history of banking is we
don't-- we do have 5,000 6,000
or so in the US.
But they're community banks.
They locally serve and really
work hard in their communities.
They know their
business community.
They know that.
And they have some
bricks and mortars.
In an online space, we know
that network effects matter.
And with network effects online,
how many of these will exist
is a great question.
Romain one more
slide on funding,
but questions is I thought
this was kind of interesting.
I don't necessarily
subscribe to it.
But they-- this one site
sort of said let's take
a look at the funding numbers.
What are their funding
numbers and how many customers
they have?
So if you take what their last
valuation number is divided
by their customers, and they
come up with this concept,
that customers are
worth about $730 apiece,
if you just average everything,
you divide their valuation
by their customer count.
It doesn't work perfectly.
It absolutely doesn't.
But you can get a sense of this
is about an account aggregation
model.
Can you build accounts,
get to a million?
Can you get to 5 or 10
million and actually service
and provide?
So what's happening is
a lot of these companies
are negative funding.
By negative funding,
what they're really doing
is they're offering
products to the public,
but they're not covering
all of their costs.
They might be offering
interest rates on the deposits.
They might be having lower
costs and fees, lower late fees
and account maintenance fees.
They might not have
account maintenance.
A lot of these will allow you to
have in essence micro payments
and micro accounts.
But how they're funding that
is the venture capitalists
are funding it, basically,
because what they're trying
to do is build valuation.
Their whole model is about
building value and then
exiting somehow and judging
when to do that exit.
Now, some of them will
get to be income positive.
But those that right now aren't
in the corona environment,
coronavirus crisis we're
in, there's a new term
that you'll hear amongst
venture capitalists, is runway.
How much runway
does a company have?
Did its last funding round,
did they raise enough money
to sustain them for six
months more or two years more?
And a lot relates to one was
their last funding round?
If their last funding round
was in the last six months
and they have enough
runway, enough cash
so that their cash burn, they
can last two or three years,
that's more optimistic than
if their runway is six months
and they haven't done
their last funding.
It's been a year ago.
They did their A round, but
they haven't done their B round.
And they've done their C round,
haven't done their D round.
And, in essence,
they have to-- a lot
of these companies in the
middle of the coronavirus crisis
have to figure out how
to extend their runway,
maybe do a suboptimal
new funding
round that doesn't
boost their valuation,
merge or consolidate.
So it's also a challenging
time, depending upon what
they hadn't anticipated--
quote, how much
runway they have,
when was their last
funding round and the like,
and have they gone
cash-flow positive?
Most of these have
not necessarily
gone cash-flow positive.
Romain I'll pause for
questions, and then I'm
going to talk about
traditional banks.
TA: So you almost just answered.
We had a question
from Alida in the chat
asking whether this
model is profitable.
GARY GENSLER: Alida it is
profitable in terms of selling
equity to venture capitalists.
It is profitable for
some of the banks that
have been sold even earlier
times to traditional banks.
And for some on bottom line has
crossed over and is profitable.
But we don't have financials
for the hundreds of challenger
and neobanks.
But by and large, most,
before the coronavirus crisis,
would have been in a
negative earnings space.
And what they were trying
to do is basically build
digital footprint,
build customer base
to get to that
first half million,
to get to that first
million, to get
to the 5 and 10 million round.
You get 5 or 10 million
customers, what you've built
is you've built a valuable
thing that somebody else might
want to buy.
And you've tended-- you've
tended to then to get
to cash-flow positive by then.
But I don't have the financials.
I wouldn't be able
to tell you which
ones of these small players
are yet cash-flow positive.
I will say this--
three to six months
from now, more of them
will consolidate,
go out of business,
or get cash-flow positive.
They'll have a need to, as
I say, extend that runway.
And then we have Carlos
with his anecdote.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have--
I have a question as it pertains
to these banks in developed
versus developing markets.
And I guess it's
for two reasons.
One is that on one
end, the extent
of the unbanked or
underbanked population in--
and especially because when you
showed the valuations, right,
Nubank is by far an outlier
in a country like Brazil.
So one is that probably
a lot of people
that are clients
of Nubank did not
previously have bank accounts or
were significantly underbanked.
And in a moment like right
now with the corona crisis,
I mean, they're going to need
these accounts more than ever,
whereas people using neobanks
in developed markets,
like the United
States, arguably,
in a lower-interest-rate
environment
might be less prompted or less
interested in actually holding
onto these accounts,
versus what they
can use in traditional banks.
GARY GENSLER: I
think you're right.
But there's one other
aspect that you imply,
but you didn't explicitly say.
It's the cost structure and
the competitive structure
in the countries.
So taking Brazil--
Brazil is a very
high-cost banking sector.
It has a lot of historic
reasons about the concentration.
It has to do with the
government involvement.
But of not just Latin
America, but around the globe,
it has, if not the
highest, one of the highest
net-interest margin.
This is the margin that
the traditional banks,
like Ita and others, are able
to charge between what they
lend money at and what
they borrow money.
That's called the
net interest margin.
And if in the US and even
in Mexico and Canada,
we're running, give or take,
around 300 basis points,
meaning what you pay a
depositor versus what
you lend on the other side.
In Brazil, it's
multiples of that.
Even for high-grade corporate
borrowers, it's more than that.
But for small, medium-sized
businesses and the public,
it's close to 10 times
that, meaning it's
20% to 30% net interest
margins for a certain sector
of the market.
So I think Nubank and the
four or five others in Brazil
had an opportunity because it's
a highly inefficient consumer
banking and small and
medium-sized banking market.
And recall from
our last class, I
said that fintech companies
have largely focused
on the household sector, whether
it's mortgages, personal loans,
credit cards, and the like.
They've focused on the consumer
sector of savings accounts
and credit card
provisions and the like.
And they focused on small
and medium-sized business.
They're not trying to compete.
Nubank is not trying to
compete with Ita about the big
corporate lending.
And they're not going
to compete in Brazil,
as about half of the-- half
of the lending at the big
corporate level is from
basically government-banked--
government-backed banks.
So I think when you look
at the developed world--
the Europe, the
US, and so forth--
we have challenges in our
banking system, but they're--
it's around those
pain points I talked
about earlier about legacy
systems and legacy user
interfaces and sometimes
high fees and so forth.
But in every country,
you have to look
at what's the inefficiency of
the current traditional banking
system?
And is online banking,
is that an opportunity
to shed a costly branch network,
shed costly legacy systems,
or, frankly, just do
it better, cheaper?
Ultimately, that's what it is
about being an entrepreneur.
Can you do a better,
cheaper, faster?
And so how have the
traditional banks reacted?
They're not staying still.
All the way back from the
online banking movement,
they were right foursquare
in the online banking
movement of the 1990s
to the late noughts.
What have they done
in the last decade?
They've started to say maybe
we have to rebrand and do
something different.
Goldman Sachs is not the
only one with Marcus.
Now, Goldman Sachs is
an investment bank.
They were not
protecting their brand.
But, as I said, Cap One in 2011
bought this big ING Direct.
Cap One said oh, for $9 billion,
we can move to this other area.
But then others are starting
to have named branded products.
JPMorgan and others
are saying we maybe
should do something that
looks like an online--
we'll even use a different
name and call it something else
and react.
So I wouldn't count out any of
these big traditional banks.
And where we are
in three or five
years is going to
be interesting.
I also would encourage
you to think big tech.
Apple Credit Card is not
quite a challenger bank.
Amazon Prime is not
But when do they, like Alibaba,
file for a banking license,
like Alibaba did and got
Ant Financial, like in Korea
Kakao has done and already is
just getting huge market share?
So I don't think that's too
much in our distant future.
I think that's near term,
that we'll see that.
Now, we have different
traditions in the US.
We have a tradition,
both in culture
and embedded in law,
about separation
of banking and commerce.
And we went through this
in the 1980s and 1990s,
when the department store
chains, like Walmart,
wanted to get into banking.
And they-- there was all this
sort of back and forth about
whether they can have banking
licenses, what type of banking
license, and industrial loan
companies and other things
really in the intricacy of
banking law and licensing.
We will have some of those
debates and challenges
as well as, I believe, Amazon
and Apple and others and Google
get further into this space.